okay this video is uh about pepper panic
saga stars
it goes along with our article about
stars and how to get three star scores
this is level 114
it's a it's an easy level to finish
but it can be difficult to get three
stars in
so i'm gonna play it real quick uh real
quickly once
and
go ahead and beat it and then we'll see
how many points i get
so i'm just going through and making my
matches and um
trying to do that in the least amount of
moves
to see where the score ends up
uh
okay so this is the most difficult match
in the level
it's an l shape
but as you can see it's not it's not a
hard level to complete
and we did a pretty good job there we
went through
fairly quickly had eight moves left
but we only had a one star score
so that tells us that the um to get this
the stars we're gonna have to
focus primarily on getting points
and not completing the level because
with eight moves left
you can see we didn't get very many
points at all
so
this time what i'm going to do is i'm
going to avoid making these matches
for as long as i can instead i'm just
going to
try to clear out the ice
try to create as much action as possible
and get points by making pepper panics
now
like i said i'm going to try to avoid
these like right here i can't any move i
make is going to make
this red three pepper match anyways
so i'm just kind of trying to decide
what the best way to make it is i'm
going to go ahead and do the shockwave
that goes down because that'll free up
this one
and
now i'm just going to try to clear out
as much ice as i can and not worry about
making that yellow match even though you
know it'll it'll happen like you just
saw
and there i had to do it again because
that was the only productive match i had
um you want to start chain reaction so
you know we have two stage fives here
we don't want to match those we want to
match another one that'll explode
because that'll guarantee us a decent
chain reaction
here's an example and we
could well we're going to have to
anyways
if this yellow pepper wasn't here
it wouldn't count but it will anyway so
and i think we got we're going to have
to make that one there there's not
really any other good moves
all right so now we're just going to try
to
keep making
peppers explode and
try not to make the l
that's actually why this level is hard
to get it in though because
whenever you're making panics to get the
points you pick up a lot of of the
matches in the cascade
so
you kind of have to get luck to not make
the match in order to get enough points
and we're really hoping that it doesn't
happen right here
all right that's good
there's an l but we don't want to make
it obviously
but if we were playing the level
normally we would have finished all
right so we hit the l there but we were
able to start the panic first and you
see we're going up pretty
pretty good here
um
six moves left this might do it and if
this turns into a panic then we'll
definitely get it
i think we're good
so that's a way you could see you took
your score from once one star to three
stars just by applying a different
strategy
obviously you know some levels
it's going to be harder to
actually finish the level when you do
that and then other ones you know it'll
be
um
it'll be necessary like stay in a
situation where you have to where you're
completing orders and the order is a
pepper panic and those ones you're out
you know you're obviously going to have
to finish soon
so you get lots of points for the moves
you have left over because you won't be
able to get extra pepper panics
and then there's other levels that are
you know completely based on luck like a
level like 132 you have to get
back-to-back pepper panics
over and over at the end where you don't
have any control over it
so if you're interested in the three
stars and how they work read our full
guide
if you have any questions leave a
comment there
definitely
you know we have guides and tips for all
the levels and we have articles about
how everything works so make sure you
visit our site